hello I'm Karen Gillen hi I'm Tom
clementia and I'm Chris Pratt
number one in honor of volume three late
I did not write these by the way but it
will seem as though I did
in honor of volume three ladies name
your three favorite things about me
I love this game you did write this yeah
just three
oh we have to even
make should we go right to the next
question okay
no I mean I'm gonna be sincere your
generosity yeah
yeah you're a twisted sense of humor
sometimes yeah let's do a dance off
because I'm the same and you're the same
too yes that's some teeth
um and you're an amazing leader too I
was gonna say that one you set the tone
a good tone for people yeah we're saying
the truth we're not lying no we haven't
been paid by you yeah and that tone like
really trickles down you know like
everybody feels it from the number one
in the cold street right that's the
truth that is one of the truth I saw
that with Amy Poehler on Parks and Rec
she was always like had a great attitude
an attitude is contagious yeah you got
to make sure yours is worth catching
what are your three most salacious
details about me that the whole world
would love to know oh my God
actually let's go next don't forget
where we came from I played the empath
of the group on screen but who of this
Bunch was the shoulder to cry on as we
wrapped up production on this finale who
was the most emotional who's the most
emotional you're very emotional
yeah everybody was pretty emotional we
all are yeah we're an emotional Bunch
we're emotional yeah and we have a lot
to be emotional about no matter what
happens next
the Galaxy still needs its Guardians so
we have a great ensemble cast but only
the three of us are here right so what's
an e
[Music]
isn't here
hey where'd it even begin oh my God uh
Sean Gunn has
six nipples
yeah like a puppy
amazing what can I say can I can I say
something that uh Vin Diesel yeah he
sounds like beautiful messages like for
Christmas
it's really nice but yeah he sent a
video Merry Christmas with like this
whole family they're like all wearing
like white it was beautiful and
inspiring and I just wanted to answer
something a little bit like weird so I
just replied to adopt me
to make it weird and then he gave it
what did he do yeah
and give it a heart what about the story
so your name is Palm Clementi F diesel
now you are we allowed to tell the story
where he wanted to save James
oh yeah that's a great story
and you're gonna know Vin sends these
videos out to all of us and to friends
of his for Christmas or they're just
emotional and and moving videos of how
much he loves you which feel kind of
random and uh but are also very
beautiful and Earnest I've been blessed
in life so Vin Diesel send a video to to
James yes but it was actually but James
had changed his number right so it went
around the person
and the person replied with man I'm not
doing well in Vegas in Vegas yeah
thinking of ending at all yeah
and so Ben was like
then called Zoe and was like we got a
charter a plane we're going to Vegas to
save James gun to save James because
James is uh outspoken about having been
sober for years and years and years like
pretty much his entire adulthood he's
been uh sober so he doesn't drink so the
idea that he was in Las Vegas about to
end it all Finn thought he had to go
save his life and he was chartered a jet
to go to Las Vegas and he was gonna go
from he's gonna go pick up James in Las
Vegas and texted Simon James at the time
was assisting for James and who's now a
producer on on the uh Guardians films
and sign and he's like wait what hotel
is James at he's like I'm pretty sure
he's staying at some hotel in Pasadena
was going to come in and
he was the heroes
would have been great for the movie
[Laughter]
in a way I almost wish it was true you
know because I think it would have got a
lot of press met a girl fell in love
that girl died but then she came back
[Music]
oh please we see a change in
relationship when a different Zoe
Saldana Zoey SOI Saldana
oh yeah as Gamora steps in how has our
relationship changed since we first met
there's this oh this is nice like
two-part question the first part is a
bit of exposition about what to expect
in Guardians of Galaxy Vol 3. uh Zoe's
character Gamora and I have a different
relationship in this film but uh
how is our our relationship changed
since we first met I mean we're closer
sir I mean yeah we're closer we've had
more time together that's kind of boring
it's such a boring answer I mean there's
like nothing like spices I know but I
would help
um uh bury a body should we just say it
yeah she killed the man and
this is and you know I helped her and
normally I I gave it I gave her the
option I said just turn yourself in
she's like yeah and then do it I was
like all right Karen brought a shovel
too so we brought the shovel so we're
all complicit I have one right at all
times I was yeah I noticed that you're
like oh do you need a bag of line a
shovel because I have one in my truck I
was like that's crazy
Karen what is something you've always
wanted to ask me
the multitude of things you've always
wanted to ask me but have not yet felt
comfortable but you want to ask me right
now right now
I want to be an actor
morning
uh trauma pain
suffering a lack of attention oh I know
what it is I was um with my family when
I was very young I lived in Minnesota
until I was three I was walking in the
mall holding my thought my mom's hand
and then I just looked up and she wasn't
there oh and I was lost in the mall and
some stranger found me we started
looking around for my family what felt
like ages finally found them
they were shopping didn't even notice I
was gone
and I think from that moment forward I
was like if I'm in the room I'm gonna be
loud and I'm gonna be noticed and I'm
not gonna I want to make sure everyone
knows I'm there just in case they get
lost they're gonna actually notice me
I'm gonna tell you something
I'm Star-Lord
what has been the coolest perk uh we
have each uh gotten since joining the
ncu free stuff
yeah you get free stuff the minute you
can afford stuff they start sending it
to you for free it's a little crazy it's
like hey I can afford to oh I don't know
okay like socks and underwear I haven't
bought socks and underwear
yeah I never get that I just get socks
underwear sent to me all the time what
I'm wearing underwear right now that
someone sent to my house I don't even
know who this person is that
um
if I say it then I guess they'll get
their uh their comeuppance what's it
called some guy named Tommy John sent me
his own way I'm wearing it
point is send me your dirty underwear
and I'll wear them
they seemed clean they were in a package
and stuff they're comfy anyways we're
always searching for a family
until we found each other where are you
gonna miss the most about this family
going it separate ways
so many things
you know laughing when I took front of
you because you're because you're
staring and yeah
you're staring yeah I know you keep like
interrupting my like eyes open naps
oh my God
I'm still nice
I'm gonna miss the jokes the banter
getting the tea cheers for a family
[Music]